il est sur un siège éjectable depuis ce
geste dimanche dernier
Luis rubialez le président de la
Fédération espagnole embrasse de force
sur la bouche l'attaquant tout juste
championne du monde Jennifer
réagit ensuite dans les vestiaires elle
se filment en direct sur Instagram
ça ne m'a pas plu hein
Luis roubiale
a pris toute l'Espagne de cours non
regardez mettez une phrase martelée 5
fois je ne démissionnerai pas le
président de la Fédération espagnole de
football se pose ensuite en victime le
faux féminisme ne cherche pas la justice
ne cherche pas la vérité ils sont en
train de préparer une exécution publique
en Espagne un homme vient d'être
condamné à verser plus de 200000 euros à
son ex-femme pour l'indemniser de tout
le boulot qu'elle a accompli dans le
foyer durant leurs années de vie
ensemble plus précisément l'équivalent
de 20 années de salaire l'explication
c'est que l'homme refusait que sa femme
travaille il voulait qu'elle s'occupe
des enfants de la maison des courses etc
il se sépare et donc elle demande une
compensation qu'elle vient d'avoir 24
ans et demi de salaire minimum ce soir
en soutien à Jenny hermoso une
cinquantaine de joueuses refusent de
jouer en équipe nationale tant que Luis
roubiales restera à son poste
[Applaudissements]
la Fédération royale espagnole de
football quant à elle soutient son
président et publie même des preuves
pour justifier sa version des faits sur
les photos on peut voir Jennifer hermoso
enlacé Luis rubialès puis le porter
selon la Fédération cela montre que la
séquence était consentie
verge et je suis désolé ben oui
mais je suis désolé je suis désolé
je suis désolé tu m'as mis du gel
jusqu'à la fin du chantage certains
produits conçus pour les femmes sont-ils
plus chers que ce destiné aux hommes
c'est ce cas constaté Oriane et elle
nous le prouve en caméra discrète dans
cette grande surface premier exemple
avec ce déodorant par exemple celui-ci
0% il est à 50 au rayon femme on va
aller voir
même il a 3,95 plus surprenant encore
nous retrouvons cet écart de prix au
rayon joué pour enfants je le regarde
plus j'ai 25 ans
j'ai fait un infarctus du myocarde ils
vont me faire lâcher le cœur
il m'énerve
avec le petit garçon sport et action il
est à 16,99 alors que le Dollhouse et
que des filles et rose bien sûr il est à
18,99 c'est quand même une différence de
prix de 2 euros pour le même joué et
cette discrimination tarifaire à un nom
la taxe rose dénoncée pour la première
fois dans les années 90 aux États-Unis
elle y est depuis interdite grâce à la
loi appelée woman tax et les marques qui
la pratiquent s'exposent à de lourdes
amendes comment s'appelle la pomme
d'Adam des femmes
en France une enquête parlementaire de
2015 a rendu la conclusion inverse la
taxe rose n'y serait pas avérée c'est
pas que dans les supermarchés on peut
retrouver aussi la taxe rose en
pharmacie dans les rayons spécialisés
sport jouer etc il faut vraiment être
attentif absolument partout alors depuis
cinq ans pépite sexiste l'association
co-fondée par Oriane traquer des noms
ces différences de prix comme ses gants
10 euros plus cher pour le modèle rose
j'ai vu un nouveau spectacle
l'expérience de la vie vous posez la
question Anne être une femme
d'expérience ou bien être toujours en
train d'expérimenter
en ce moment vous en êtes où
vous y allez là
vous êtes sur ces antibiotiques je vous
présente Véronique et Davina
musique
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'on peut dire que tu as fait
honneur à la Suisse est-ce qu'ils t'ont
remis une médaille du chocolat ben non
que dalle mais un peu de reconnaissance
de l'amour mais si vous voulez sortir
les chéquiers là
je suis marié ah vous êtes mariés
comment était la demande en mariage
alors
mon cher étendre Fabien m'a demandé en
mariage sur un trottoir à Choisy-le-Roi
avec
déjà deux secondes c'est très très
romantique il a réussi à créer une
véritable relation toxiques avec les
Français c'est comme dans un couple on
en connaît tous des coupes qui ont une
relation toxique je veux dire il passe
sa vie à s'embrouiller il s'humilie les
uns les autres en public ils prennent
semble-t-il plaisir à rabaisser l'autre
c'est un peu ça je veux dire la relation
d'Emmanuel Macron au peuple français
elle est de cette nature on était sur un
trottoir à Choisy-le-Roi d'accord
pendant une soirée voilà on est sorti on
a pris l'air voilà et puis bah là il
s'est dit tiens pourquoi pas c'est sympa
la sortie un serre-joint un serre-joint
quelle amende un couple risque-t-il si
les surpris au cours des bas amoureux
sur la plage
c'est déjà arrivé à quelqu'un non
dommage dommage
[Rires]
voilà alors
qui sont là c'est ici il y a une tempête
mais pour l'instant personne n'est
blessé
allez on s'en va mourir au revoir
[Musique]
expliquez-moi le coup du serre-joint je
sais pas il avait une bague mais il
était peut-être pas sûr de la taille ou
je sais pas du coup il s'est dit tiens
je fais ça puis comme il a de l'humour
bah voilà mais c'est passé j'ai dit oui
mais c'est quand même beau mais c'est
magnifique je m'en souviendrai toute ma
vie
à tous les gens qui sont là qui ont
participé à ce chemin
[Applaudissements]
et je vous dis merci mais je suis très
fier de moi parce que
en entrant dans la proposition c'est
quelque chose que je voulais j'ai pas
caché dès le début vraiment merci je
suis tellement heureux
j'ai tellement aimé merci
il y a des trucs amusants aussi et ça
c'était en Géorgie je me suis rien que
la photo elle est amusante c'est un
laveur qui s'est retrouvé coincé
par les parties intimes collées à des
rails de train ouais avoir les parties
intimes collées à des rails dans le
showbiz on appelait ça une bonne soirée
chez Pierre Palmade mais
franchement si avec tout ça vous passez
pas une bonne semaine je ne peux plus
rien faire pour vous